we've talked a lot about linear
transformations what I want to do in
this video and actually the next few
videos is to show you how to essentially
design linear transformations to do
things to vectors that you want them to
do so we already know that if I have
some linear transformation T and it's a
mapping from RN to R M that we can
represent T what T does to any vector in
X or the mapping of T in of X in RN to
RM we can represent it as some matrix
times the vector X where this would be
an M by n matrix M by n matrix and we
know that we can always construct this
matrix that any linear operation any
linear transformation can be represented
by a matrix this way and we can
represent it by taking our identity
matrix you've seen that before
by taking the identity matrix with n
rows and n columns so it literally just
looks like this so it's a 1 and then it
has n minus 1 zeros all the way down
then it's a 0 1 and then there
everything else is zeros all the way
down and so essentially you just have
ones down as diagonal it's an N by n
matrix all of these are zeros just like
that you take your diet identity a
matrix and your prop and you up and you
perform the transformation on each of
its columns on each of its columns and
we call each of these columns the
standard basis for RN so this is column
e 1 this is column e 2 and it has n
columns en and each of these columns are
of course members of RN because this is
an N n rows and n columns matrix and we
know that a our matrix a can be
represented as the transformation being
operated on each of these columns so the
transformation on e 1 and the
transformation on e 2 so forth and so on
all the way to the transformation the en
and this is a really useful thing to
know because it's very easy to operate
any transformation on each of these
basis vectors that only have a 1
kind of in its corresponding dimension
or endurance court with respect to the
corresponding variable and everything
else is zero so let's you know all of
this is review let's actually use this
information to construct some
interesting transformations so let's
start with some set in R in RN and
actually everything I'm going to do is
going to be an r2 but you can extend a
lot of this into just general dimensions
but we're dealing with r2 right here
obviously it's only two dimensions right
here let's say we have a triangle formed
by the points formed by the points let's
say the first point is right here let's
say it's the point three two three two
and then you have the point let's say
that your next point in your triangle is
the point well let's just make it the
point - three - three - I shouldn't have
written that as a fraction I know I did
that three - then you have the point -
three - and that's this point right here
- three - and then let's say just for
fun let's say you have the point let's
say we have the point or the vector the
position vector right 3 - 2 3 - 2 which
is right here now each of these are
position vectors and I can draw them I
could draw this 3 2 is in the standard
position by kind of drawing an arrow
like that I could do the - 3 - and its
standard position like that and 3 - 2 I
could draw like that but more than the
actual position vectors I'm more
concerned with the positions that they
specify and we know that if we take the
set of all of the positions or all of
the position vectors that specify the
triangle that essentially formed by
connecting these dots the transformation
of this set the transformation of this
set so we're going to apply some
transformation of that is essentially
you take the transformation of each of
these endpoints and then you connect the
dots in the same order and we saw that
several videos ago but let's actually
design a transformation here so let's
say we want to let's just write down in
words what we want to do with our
without what whatever we start in our
domain let's say we want to reflect
around the x-axis reflect around around
the well actually let's reflect around
the y-axis around the y-axis so we
essentially want to flip it over we want
to flip it over that way so I'm kind of
envisioning something that'll look
something like that when we flip it over
so we're going to reflect it around the
y-axis and let's say we want to we want
to stretch stretch in y direction by two
in y direction times two so what I
envision we're going to flip it over
like this what I just drew here and then
we want to stretch it so we're going to
first flip it that's kind of step one
and then step two is we're going to
stretch it so instead of looking like
this it'll be twice as tall so it'll
look like this without necessarily
stretching the X so how can we do that
so the first idea of reflecting around
the y axis
right so what we want is this point that
was a minus three and the x coordinate
right there we want this point to have
its same y-coordinate we want it to
still have a two there and I'm calling
the second coordinate here our y
coordinate I call it I could call that
our X 2 coordinate but we're used to
dealing wet with the y coordinate when
we graph things so I'll just keep
calling it the y coordinate what we want
is this this negative 3 to turn to a
positive 3 and week because we want this
point to end up over here and we want
this positive 3 here to end up becoming
a negative 3 over here and we want this
positive 3 for the x coordinate to end
up as a negative 3 over there so you can
imagine all we're doing is we're
flipping the sign when we this
reflection around y this is just
equivalent to flipping the sign flipping
the sign of the x coordinate so this
statement right here is equivalent to
minus 1 times the
x-coordinate so let me call that or you
know let's call that x x-1 because this
is X 1 X 1 and then stretching in the
y-direction so what does that mean that
means that whatever whatever height we
have here so this next step here is
whatever height we have here I want it
to be two times as much so right here
this coordinate is 3/2 if I didn't do
this first step first I would want to
make it 3 4 I want to make two times the
y coordinate so the next thing I want to
do is I want to do two times well I
could either call it well let me just
call it the the y coordinate it's a
little bit different convention than
I've been using but I'm just calling
these vectors instead of calling them X
1 and X 2 I'm saying that my vector is
in R 2 the first time I'm calling the X
term or the X entry and the second term
I'm calling the Y entry but it's the
same idea that we've been doing before
I'm just switching to this notation
because we're used to thinking of this
as the Y axis as opposed to the X 1 and
the X 2 axis so how do we construct this
transformation I mean I can write it
down in kind of transformation words I
could say I could define my
transformation as T of some vector X let
me write it this way T of some vector X
Y is going to be equal to I want to take
minus 1 times the X so I'm going to
minus the X and then I'm going to
multiply 2 times the Y so that's how I
could just write it in transformation
language and that's pretty
straightforward but how would I actually
construct a matrix for this so what you
do is you just take your we're dealing
in r2 so you start off with the identity
matrix in r2 which is just 1 0 0 1 and
you apply this transformation to each of
the columns of this identity matrix to
each of the columns of that identity
matrix so if you apply this if you apply
the transformation to this first column
what you get so what we're going to do
is we're going to create a new matrix a
and say that is equal to the
transformation of
let me write it like this transformation
of 0 of 1 0 that's going to be our new
column we're just going to transform
this column and then the second column
the second column is going to be the
transformation of that column so it's
transformation of 0 1 just like that and
so what are these equal to the
transformation of 1 0 so let me write it
down here in green
so a is equal to what's the
transformation of 1 0 where X is 1 where
we just take the minus of the X term so
we get minus 1 and then 2 times the y
term so 2 times 0 is just 0 now to do
the second term the minus of the 0 term
is just minus 0 so that just stays is 0
and then multiply 2 times the y term so
2 times y is going to be equal to 2
times 1 so it's equal to 2 so now we can
describe this transformation so now we
could say the transformation of some
vector X Y we can describe it as a
matrix vector product it is equal to
minus 1 0 and 0 2 times our vector times
X Y and let's apply it to to verify that
it works the verify that our matrix
works so this first point and I'll try
to do it color coded let's do this first
point right here this is minus 3/2 so
that's minus 3/2 so what is what is
minus 3/2 I'll do it right over here I
could just look at that so what is 1
minus 1 0 and 0 2 times minus 3/2 well
this is just a straight up matrix vector
product minus 1 times minus 3 is
positive 3 plus 0 times 2 so plus 0 so
this is 3 and then 0 times minus 3 is 0
plus 2 times 2 so this is 3/4 so that
point right there will now become
the 0.34 it now becomes that point right
there let's look at this point right
here the 0.32 so let's take our
transformation matrix - 1 0 0 2 times 3
- this is equal to minus 1 times 3 is
minus 3 plus 0 times 2 so it's just
minus 3 you have 0 times 3 which is 0
plus 2 times 2 which is 4
0 plus so you get that point so this
point by our transformation T becomes
minus 3 4 so minus 3 4 and I kind of
switch in my terminology I say it
becomes or you could say it's mapped to
if you want to be kind of used the
language that I use when I introduce the
ideas of functions and transformation
this point is mapped to this point in R
2 and then finally let's look at this
point right here apply our
transformation matrix that we've
engineered let's multiply minus 1 0 0 2
times this point right here which is 3
minus 2 3 minus 2 which is equal to
minus 1 times 3 is minus 3 and then 0
times minus 2 is just 0 so this becomes
minus 3 and then 0 times 3 is 0 2 times
minus 2 is minus 4 so minus 3 minus 4 so
this point right here becomes minus 3
minus 4 becomes that point right there
and we know that the set in R 2 that
connects these dots by the same
transformation will be mapped to the set
in R 3 that connects these dots we've
seen that already I think those three
videos ago so the image the image of
this set that I've drawn here this
triangle is just a set of points
specified by a set of vectors the image
of that set of position vectors
specifies these points right here
specifies the points that I'm drawing
right here let me see if I'm doing it
right there you go just like that
and lo and behold it has done what we
wanted to do we flipped it over so that
we got kind of this side on to the other
side like that and then we stretched it
and we stretched it in the y-direction
and we see that it has stretched by a
factor of two we flipped it first and
then we stretched it by a factor of two
and in general any of these operations
can be can be performed and you can
always go back to the basics you can
always say look I can write my
transformation in this type of form that
I can just apply that to my to my basis
vectors or the columns in my identity
matrix but a general theme is is any of
these any of these transformations that
literally just scale and neither the X
or Y direction and when I or essentially
just well you could say scale they can
either shrink or expand in the X or Y
direction or flip in the X or Y
direction creating a reflection these
are going to be diagonal made diagonal
matrices diagonal matrices diagonal
matrices and why are they diagonal
matrices because they only have nonzero
terms along their diagonal this is a two
by two case if I did a three by three it
would be zeros everywhere except along
the diagonal and it makes a lot of sense
because this first term is essentially
what you're doing to the x one term the
second term is what you're doing to the
x2 term if you had or the Y term in our
example if I had multiple terms if I in
this was a three by three that would be
what I would do to the third dimension
then the next term would be what I would
do to the fourth dimension so you could
expand this idea to an arbitrary RN
anyway this whole point of this video is
to kind of introduce you to this idea of
creating custom transformations and I
think you're already starting to realize
this could be very useful if you want to
do especially in computer programming if
you're going to do some graphics or
create some type of multi-dimensional
games